there's nothing wrong with having big
goals but i think the problem is that
big goals on their own
don't really do anything they don't
inspire any action today
so if your goal is like well one day i'm
gonna be a billionaire well what does
that tell you to do right now
nothing right like there's nothing
there's no like plausible sequence you
can work out in your head where
me doing x right now is going to make me
a billionaire you know
30 years from now so you set a goal that
i'm gonna you know do this in a year
and then what does that mean you're
gonna do this month and then
from that month what are you gonna do
this week what are you gonna do today
what are you gonna do right now
welcome to episode 95 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i interviewed scott
young
author of ultra learning his book helps
people develop
habits and skills to learn new
information quickly
we talked about alternative education
models self-education
habit stacking dealing with distractions
goal setting
learning styles building routines and
more
this episode is brought to you by
selfauthoring.com
if you like this episode if you learned
something please remember to hit
subscribe
self-authoring i thought would be a good
ad here it was developed by my dad over
the last 30 years with the help from two
other phds at mcgill and harvard the
self-authoring suite is a series of
online writing programs that
collectively help you explore your past
present and future
i cannot tell you how important it is to
write out your traumatic experiences
in order to get them out of your head
writing has been one of the ways i've
stayed sane
throughout crazy amounts of stress diet
two of course
sleep etc anyway sometimes you need time
before writing out trauma
you don't want to re-traumatize yourself
all over again self-authoring
can help with that the present authoring
program has two modules
the first helps you understand and
rectify your personality faults
the second helps you understand and
develop your personality virtues
the future authoring program helps you
envision a meaningful
healthy and productive future three to
five years down the road
and to develop a detailed implementable
plan to make that future a reality
and past authoring helps you work
through your past
traumatic experiences use codemp to get
10 percent off at selfauthoring.com
i hope you enjoy this episode i hope you
learned something
[Music]
scott young welcome to my podcast oh
it's great to be here thanks for having
me
so i invited you on because i got your
book
ultra learning and i thought my audience
would have some interest in
rapid learning which is what you seem to
specialize in so
before we get started and i ask you a
whole bunch of questions
sure can you give a brief background
about who you are and
what you do yeah so i'm a writer online
and i guess the thing i'm sort of known
for is taking on these sort of weird
self-education projects
so about 10 years ago i did the one that
i'm most well known for i guess which i
called the mit
challenge it was right after i graduated
from school i was thinking about going
back to school to do a
degree in computer science and i noticed
that mit
the you know one of the best
universities in the world posts a lot of
their material online for free
and i'd taken one or two classes from
there before and
it just kind of occurred to me maybe you
could try to
try to do some sort of benchmark where
you do
their version of a degree like the
material that they have and try to learn
all the content that you would learn if
you were an mit student but without
going to mit
so that was a project i did over 12
months
in 2011 and then i've done other
projects since where i've learned
languages
and drawing and other things like that
and i documented on my blog
and i decided to write this book most
recently about not only my own
experiences with
taking on unusual projects but a lot of
the people who inspired me
people who you know have started
businesses who have learned dozens of
languages who have done all sorts of
incredible feats of
self-education and learning so that you
know people can benefit from these ideas
both for inspiration and to
see how to do it themselves okay that's
fantastic
so what was it that you learned at mit
what did you decide to take
uh computer science so i they have the
most courses i think probably for
computer science although it's getting a
lot better now this was 10 years ago so
there's even more courses and for more
schools now too
and so the idea was i wonder if you
could
you know pass the exams that an mit
student would take in
you know physics and electrical
engineering and computer science
uh not only to learn programming but to
have the kind of
education that people spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars for
without having to leave the comfort of
your apartment
and did you pass that it was good yeah
yeah so that's what i did so there was
33 classes and
um it's self-graded and you're doing it
yourself so it's not the same as getting
an mit degree but
in terms of the content that you're
learning there's a pretty good overlap i
would say it's pretty close to what an
mit student would do
okay that's very interesting so you can
just
you can just save you you can't get the
credentials at the end
well i think there's there are ways if i
was really serious about getting the
credentials that you can
uh do it not with the approach that i
was doing but a friend of mine j
cross did a similar kind of program
where he did examination test by
examination or something like this
and he was able to get credits at
colleges sort of using their loopholes
of like
just being able to take the final exam
so in my case it didn't really matter i
already had an undergraduate degree and
for me it was mostly about
the knowledge and learning what i wanted
to learn but i think
that's sort of the point is that there's
lots of different ways that you can
approach these kinds of things
so theoretically i don't know if this is
something that you want to tell people
but theoretically
you could learn you know hundreds and
thousands of dollars worth of
information
online from top universities and then go
to a different college do their final
exams and get the credentials
well yeah you can think about different
schools yeah i think like
again i i'm not a specialist in the
getting the credentials uh
part yeah i think um there's ways that
you can do it and one of the other
people that i documented
in the book steve pavlina did three
semesters at a university where he got a
double major in math and computer
science so he kind of did what i did he
just actually went to school
and he just like stacked up his courses
and did it that way so
it's not impossible to do that and i
think uh
part of the reason that i was interested
in writing this book is that there's
become this whole phenomenon of like
coding boot camps and
these sort of non-traditional university
alternatives
i mean programming is probably one of
the best fields where
even if you don't have a background in
computer science you can still you know
make
200 000 a year doing it as a job and so
i think it's a pretty good um central
case for the argument in favor of doing
this kind of learning
okay so i i found it strange when i was
in university that i had to combine
that you had to take certain courses in
different semesters and you had to
spread out some of your learning
uh so you'd have to take you know six
courses and two of them would be arts
and four of them would be sciences and
it was all spread out
um i haven't taught another topic i have
a toddler and
i've been looking into ways to teach
kids really quickly
and i have a nanny from russia and she
said there's this russian technique
where you learn you know all of your
math in high school
in like three months when you're 12
because they
do one topic at a time rather than
spreading out all the topics so
what are your thoughts on that well i
knew rapidly my basic
yeah my basic feeling is just that i
don't think the
existing educational institutions are
like particularly well designed for
learning per se
it sounds kind of a radical thing to say
but i think
what you have in universities is that
they're optimized for a lot of different
constraints so one of the constraints
is that we want to have grades that you
know show how everyone ranks up against
everyone else
so that makes it so that you have to
focus on doing very standardized tests
you have to
do it in a particular way for that you
have to pace the class so that it has to
be
you know for the median student so if
you're a bit faster
it's boring if you're a bit uh slower
it's really frustrating and you kind of
stop paying attention
there's all these little constraints and
obstacles and so i'm not here to suggest
that i have some new way of doing school
that
everyone should be doing what i'm doing
i'm really here just to suggest
alternatives and to suggest different
ways of thinking about these problems
because
i know that most people aren't going to
do what i did but i think
it's worthwhile because if you look
around like most people
what they did is they went to school for
four years they you know they did this
very sort of
linear narrow path and i think there's
just so many examples of people doing it
in a different way that
uh it's worth exploring you know some of
the potentials of that
okay so what would you suggest people
look into
or how would you suggest people look
into learning if the
regular four-year university program
isn't something that interests them
well i think the starting point for me
would be to figure out what really
interests you and what you'd really like
to accomplish
so i think part of the problem is that
we often
detach school from you know what
motivates us to
to learn things and do things yeah so if
you're really interested in
entrepreneurship
like do a deep dive in that right like
do a deep dive in how do you start a
business how do you
get that going if you're really
interested in being a writer you know
start a blog write regularly you know
research and figure out how to become a
better writer figure out some topic
that you can you know do journalism in
or interview people if you want to be an
artist i mean the list goes on but i
think part of the problem is that we
often
okay i'm gonna study this in school and
you know do these exams and and get this
credential at the end
but it's often disconnected from you
know well what am i going to be doing
after with my life
right it's just it's a totally separate
process and
i think it's kind of unfair to kids
sometimes that we put them in this super
artificial environment for
you know i don't know 15 16 years
and then once they're done kind of scold
them for not having it all figured out
not having a job and not being able to
make money when you've really
removed them from all of that for so
long that the only world they know
is how to work in school and and how to
get grades and please the teacher that
this whole idea of you know going out
and doing things that are productive and
useful to society
is often if not alien it's just it's a
definitely a shift you know that's why
we always talk about like in the real
world after school like
why should there be this uh disjunction
between what you learn and what you do
so your suggestion is if people are
trying to learn something they should be
doing it
is that what you suggest well i think
that would be a pretty good start
honestly like
uh it's it's amazing to me that you know
if you look back in history there's just
this
long chain of people learning by
apprenticeship
by a you know being introduced to a
community that practices something
and this whole idea of you know
universal education where you remove
people from the environment and get them
to sit in desks and you lecture at them
for for dozens of years is a relatively
new invention
and i don't want to suggest that it
doesn't have a place i mean i i've taken
so many online courses now i'm
definitely
a fan so i'm not criticizing from
perspective that no one should ever go
to school
but just that it is somewhat unnatural
in that way that you know the way that
we learn how to do most things is by
doing it
by some sort of form of apprenticeship
by being kind of slowly brought into the
community that practices it
and so you know i think that that's
something that's worth considering
especially if you feel like school just
doesn't fit your personality or what
you're interested in how do you feel
about unpaid internships
well i think that they often get a lot
of flack because
they're seen as somewhat exploitative
and i think that definitely
can be the case i mean you can
definitely intern somewhere
where all the real work gets done buying
closed doors and you're bringing people
coffee and so you're just basically like
you know free labor doing something
that's not
you're not really learning and so i
think it's true of apprenticeship
generally that there's always this kind
of tension
between the master who wants to get free
labor out of the apprentice and the
apprentice who wants to learn but then
is maybe a competitor to the master and
so this has been a tension that's been
happening for centuries i think that
unpaid work and unpaid internships can
be really valuable but they have to be
evaluated on a case-by-case basis like i
definitely don't think there's anything
glorious about getting coffee for
executives while like who knows what
they're actually doing for the work
but at the same time i think it's
there's nothing wrong with
okay well i'm not going to get paid to
do this right now but
i'm going to figure out how this works
and then use that to get my own job
so you just have to evaluate whether
it's benefiting you in each individual
opportunity when i was young
i remember i remember friends who had
unpaid internships and thinking oh
that's exploitative they're taking being
taken advantage of and then
since i've been working i've been like
you know what if you
if you're underneath the right person
and you get to spend a year
learning what they know that is so much
more valuable than paying for an
education depending on who you're under
if you can be under the right person
so they're not they're definitely all
bad yeah and i think
it's something as well that it's kind of
what you bring to it
as well like i think part of it can be
you know
i know this from having employed people
that you can hire people and they they
want to be told what to do
and uh so you know you give tasks for
them and you find things that they can
work
on um but often what you're looking for
is someone who takes the initiative that
like oh what are you doing how can i
help with that like
and they they want to work into it so i
think there is a personality element
in there as well that the people that
i've seen interviewed that have
managed to use the unpaid internship or
the kind of low
paid sort of starting job to good
heights are someone that they really
treat it as a learning opportunity
and i think maybe that's part of the
problem with the school system generally
is that we kind of teach
people this um model where it's really
like do what you're told
and uh it's it's kind of if there's an
axis between really
you know this authoritative
obedience-driven approach in a more
entrepreneurial
approach i think if you're going to be
in an environment where people are doing
something
you really have to take initiative to
you know see what they're doing to start
doing the real work and not just the
coffee getting and stuff and so there is
maybe a bit of tension there um
i've been working on a recent project
where i've been learning a lot about
apprenticeship and
there's all sorts of stuff about people
working on you know construction sites
and how the actual
people who know the skill there can be
some like hostility almost to like break
into
being able to learn what they're wanting
to do you know they want to shut you at
all i'd like keep this person away from
all the tools and stuff
and so i definitely agree there can be
tensions in those environments
about the right way to learn things but
i think it's useful to
consider other alternatives i think we
we tend to take
learning is education a little bit too
seriously in our culture
yeah it's almost yeah you'd think that
in elementary school or
at least in high school there'd be an
opportunity to do more
somewhere instead of just be do just
doing what you're told
uh to develop that kind of
entrepreneurship
well this is another thing that i think
is is really important too that a lot of
education has a little bit of a perverse
incentive to
be anti-vocational like that the more
vocational it is the less prestigious it
is so you think of like
a community college versus university
which is more practical usually
community college though teaching you
things that you actually do on the job
whereas university they're teaching you
abstract theories
and this is often justified in this idea
of generality that well the university
is teaching you like the deeper
principles and the community college is
just like well you're not smart enough
for that so we're gonna just teach you
tricks but i have a different story of
that which is that
um if you want to like show people that
okay i'm really smart generally i'm i'm
a smart person i'm a bd and i can go
through this four year college program
then it serves this kind of signaling
function because the research on
transfer really
shows that a lot of these aspirations
that we're teaching students super
general ideas that they
you know go through their program and
they have all these really deep
principles
i mean the research is pretty bad that
that it's actually fulfilling that
function so
i tend to be more inclined to the idea
that
um you know if we were trying to help
students uh
live better lives we should probably
spend more time teaching them what they
actually need to do
which it sounds a little bit you know
obvious but
it's kind of there's a little bit of a
perversion there in just
how the more prestigious the education
is the more detached it is from
actual practical necessities of life
okay i appreciated that i i tend to
agree
okay so i was looking through your
instagram looking through your blogs
you've got a lot of like fun little
short snippets of wisdom so one thing
you talked about that i think people
should know about is habit stacking
so can you describe what habit stacking
is yeah so
i think this is an idea where if you're
trying to build a more complicated
habit like you want to start going to
the gym you want to start studying you
want to learn a language
part of the problem is that a lot of the
stuff is new right you're you're doing a
lot of unfamiliar
things and so there's a lot of friction
and resistance to it so this idea is
just that you
slowly build up the habit that you want
to create so you start with sort of a
very simple thing like okay i'm gonna
just go to the gym
right and then you build into having a
larger and larger workout so this is
something that
you know i don't claim any credit for
this idea this is related to
um uh bj fox tiny habits um
james clear a friend of mine who wrote
the intro my book wrote atomic habits
and i think thinking in terms of habits
can be really valuable
for the goals that you want to set
because so much of what we do is just
routine
we just do the same thing every single
day and we're
very used to this familiarity so if you
can accelerate that process of becoming
familiar with something
it's easier to stick to requires less
willpower less mental effort to sustain
okay and how would you familiarize
yourself with something faster
so well there's a couple ways one is
just to be really consistent with your
routine so if you always go to the gym
at 5 00 pm right after work
then when it's 5 pm right after work it
feels very
like oh i go to the gym right now
whereas if you try to go to the gym
every day but it's at a different time
every day
the cues in your environment sometimes
after work you go to the gym sometimes
you watch tv sometimes you do this
and so that ambiguity as to it's after
work what do i do
can create a little bit of attention
because there's an easier option a
harder option and you have to make that
decision
so consistency is one way another way is
just to make the habit you're doing more
rewarding so if you have it so that
you know you don't like lifting weights
but you like going to a dance class you
go to a dance class it's more fun
you know it's it's a more rewarding
alternative um so there's lots of
different ways that you can
improve how you set up habits so that
they become conditioned
and i think even just the idea of this
habit stacking where you focus on the
initiating moment
is very powerful too because once you're
at the gym it's a lot easier to continue
with the workout because you already
have the context of being at the gym to
sustain
um your motivation at least somewhat
whereas when you're at home and you're
watching tv
you don't have the context of the gym to
be like i should work out right now it
requires a lot of effort to you know
turn off netflix and
start exercising and so if you can think
about these sort of these little moments
of breaks between
activities or routines in your day where
you can hook
on a new habit that you want to work on
it can definitely lower the effort
required to do it
okay that's an interesting way to think
about it so instead of thinking i'm
going to go to the gym and lift weights
you think i'm just going to go to the
gym yeah i mean
i think this is something that is a
strategy that you can apply
especially if you've tried you know i'm
going to work out and it's failed for
you in the past then
i think it's totally reasonable to say
well i've been
on and off with this exercise habit of
mine for like
you know years let's try right now just
for the next month i'm going to go to
the gym every day
at this particular time even if i just
have a 10 minute workout
i mean i'm not saying that that's
necessarily ideal from the weight loss
or fitness or whatever perspective you
have that got you into going to the gym
but i know a lot of people that have had
success with that when the alternative
was
okay i'm gonna do this like crazy
workout program but it's inconsistent
and i have to every single time force
myself to do it
so i think the the habit approach has
some limitations
i've written about that before as well
but i definitely think for the person
who isn't used to thinking
of their behavior this way they're used
to thinking about all their problems in
terms of
discipline or motivation or or you know
something like that the habit approach
definitely has a lot going for it
do you have tricks for people if they
have to learn something they don't want
to learn
is there any way to make that yeah um so
i think
part of what i try to do is is reframing
the problem
um so there's lots of different ways you
can do it but i think
some of the challenges that you see what
you're doing and you have some
unpleasantness about it
so one way of doing it is how can i
focus on some aspect of the problem that
i'm working on that makes it interesting
to me
and so i think one reason a lot of
people don't want to learn something is
because they have some kind of
i don't say fear but like negative
feeling associated with it particularly
if you know i've got a big test
and i'm worried i'll fail right so every
time i sit down to study
i start to think about the test i start
to think about how awful it's going to
feel when i don't pass the test and you
just feel this
knot in your stomach and you want to go
watch netflix
and so if you can reframe that problem
of well what i'm doing right now
is not trying to pass the test not not
trying to get all the questions right
i'm just trying to go through the
questions and get like a first pass or
something
that can be helpful another way is if
it's really boring for you that the
problem isn't you know a fear of failure
but this is just really boring and
tedious
how can you make it into a challenge how
can you make it into something where
okay how can i organize myself so i can
do this so
i know people that if they have to go
through a pro like a set of test
questions that they're just
practicing on you know they make make a
little thing where they count how many
test questions they did every day and
then that becomes like a score for them
that they can keep it up
another thing you can do is find a
reason to be interested and i know
that's not always
immediately possible but i think like a
lot of the way we're presented
information is just sort of here's what
you have to learn
and it's kind of removed from its
context it's removed from why it matters
it removes it's removed from all the
social connections that would make it
kind of interesting to know
and i think if you can re-establish
those it can be more interesting so if
you're you know
in a chemistry class and you have to
like memorize all these symbols or
something like this
it might be interesting to know like why
were these discovered or what was what's
the history
of this or what's the situation that
surrounds it or how do people use this
to
cure cancer and build rocket ships and
stuff and it's not that you have to
master all of that surrounding context
i'm not trying to create an additional
learning chore for everyone
but i think situating what you're trying
to learn in terms of
why is this really cool and important um
is
is a skill uh because it's often given
to you in this sort of
decontextualized way where like of
course it's boring because
you have no idea why it matters okay
so i completely agree with that i took
sciences
and i had a hell of a time with like
calculus and physics because
i'd be learning you know calculations
and i'd have
absolutely no idea why because she was
like you just insert the numbers and
that's the answer
it's like well how on earth did they
come up with that that doesn't make any
sense
so um how do you implement that kind of
thing if you're trying to learn
something like
coding well i mean i think there's a
really strong example usually if you're
learning coding you're learning it to
code
something right and so for me i feel
like the way to learn coding
the ideal way to learn coding is to have
some project in mind that you want to
work on
um it could be a personal project or it
could be something more in the line of
like
i want to be able to build a website so
i can get a job right so i'm not here to
tell you exactly what your goal ought to
be
but i think with a practical activity
like that
it's very good to start thinking like
well how am i going to use this and i
think that that's one of the problems as
well is that we often get stuck
on the kind of training material and i
don't want to say the training material
is not important obviously for a skill
like programming
you just give someone a you know blank
text document okay write some code
you're not gonna be able to do it if you
haven't done some initial practice
but at the same time it's very easy to
get stuck in like working on the toy
problems that are
in the book or in the course that you're
on and it just it's hard to shift over
to
okay i'm gonna make something that i
actually care about like
you know a lot of people i know who got
started with programming started making
video games and it's not because there's
something very particular about video
games but it's just something you can
wrap your head around as
this is something cool that i could make
right um and yeah i think you could do
it
where i know another person i was
talking to how um she got really good at
it was that she was doing sort of
financial
analysis in her job she was a finance
person and she started learning
programming and it was from the
perspective of a lot of work i
do i could write a code to do this
automatically and just
and so i mean that to me is where the
motivation comes like why do we want to
learn a language so you can speak to
people if it's just to know
words in a phrase book then like who
cares right
it's to communicate with people if you
want to learn code is to
do something productive to make
something that's cool so
i think that that's really important is
to try to establish that connection with
what you're really trying to do early on
okay so you said you had ultra learning
methods for
language learning is that yeah well
this is something that's uh not like
it's definitely not my idea
but it's strange to me how when i
suggested to people
it sounds kind of radical and this is
just the idea that um
we approach learning languages by and
large by you sit in a classroom where
someone like
writes words there and maybe you do a
little bit of mock dialogue with the
teacher and you
do grammar exercises which are like fill
in the blank and this kind of stuff
and i've met a number of people now who
have done
these you know what would have been
incredible to me
you know 15 years ago projects where
they go to a country and they're able to
have conversations with people
in you know a couple of months and it's
not just the traveling and being
immersed it's the
actually starting to have interactions
with people in the language very very
early on
and so uh benny lewis who's someone that
i feature quite
strongly in the book um i had him on my
podcast
oh perfect yeah so you know his whole
approach is speak from day one which is
basically you should try to have some
interaction in this language you want to
learn
from the very first day which is not how
it's normally approached
i did a project um with a good friend of
mine vat
that was sort of loosely inspired by
benny and we kind of went a step further
where we
used what we called the no english rules
so we went to the country from the first
day we tried not to speak english to
each other or to anyone that we would
meet
and the advantage that had is it yeah
your spanish or
mandarin chinese is terrible at the
beginning but
all the social interactions that you
form around you
are in that language and it becomes kind
of this self-reinforcing cycle so you
start
learning it much more quickly and so
even you know a month in you're already
having productive interactions and
you're getting stuff done
and i think it really helps if you're an
environment where
you have to use the language i mean it's
a little harder if you're
you know i'm in canada right now and if
i were to you know
do this to learn mandarin it would be a
little harder because most people also
speak english right
so i'm very rarely going to be in a
situation where speaking mandarin is
better than speaking english at least in
the beginning
but if you are in a situation where you
can
encourage this kind of rule or this sort
of i'm going to stick to speaking this
language
you can really learn it quite a bit
faster and it's
it's sort of a funny thing because among
language learning
sort of people who do this uh it's kind
of accepted as like well yeah of course
you know of course you can learn like
several languages if you do this and you
can have conversations in all of them
um it's just when i talk to people
who've never tried anything like this
before they've only gone through like 40
years of high school spanish
it just sounds impossible so it is one
of those strange things you know
anthropologists for instance it's like
quite common to like go to
uh you know some country and then you're
learning it from scratch
i document that in my book as well and
so just to me it seems like there's a
discrepancy among the people who really
learn and speak other languages and
um how we're often taught how to do it
especially in north america
yeah i wonder if part of the problem
with um a lot of north americans only
knowing english is that
the way we're taught in i'm from canada
too so the way i was taught in the
schooling system was
the wrong way right from when i was
little and then i was always like
it's hard to learn a language period
because i learned the wrong way going
forward i mean
like you said in class writing down
verbs
yeah i i know i i mean i think
it's hard to say i definitely i
definitely want to give educators some
credit because
i think if you know language learning
stuff you're
you understand some of these problems
and so you're trying to get the kids to
use it and speak it and i know lots of
people who you know being canadian went
through the french immersion system i
did not
but they went through the french
immersion system and that was the whole
idea of the french immersion system was
that they're going to learn french by
doing this
but i think the problem is that it's
hard to impose
these sort of ideas from the outside so
it's hard to take a group of kids and
force them to do something that
well it's easier for us to speak english
to each other because our
first language is english not french and
so we learned to listen to the teacher
and we learned to
respond in class but when we when it's
recess time we speak in english because
why wouldn't we
and so i think that's one advantage you
do have as an adult is that
if you see the rationale for why this
would work you can commit yourself to it
and so for me that was a big shift was
oh okay
what i need to do is be really strict
with myself
when i'm really terrible with the
language to only speak it in the
beginning and that can kind of bootstrap
having these sort of normal-ish
conversations where i can add on all the
grammar i'm studying or vocabulary or
other things that
you do in the classroom but they like
hang on to the practical ability i have
you know similar with programming like
if you're the kid who
was making video games when you were in
high school you're often very good at
picking up the programming concepts
because you just have this rich
background of like well i've been doing
programming for so long
whereas if you've only done it in these
classroom examples it can just seem like
impossibly difficult and like how can
everyone actually do this
and so i think that that can be some of
the challenge
do you think um i remember being told
that there are different types of
learning that some people are audio
learners some people are video uh
audio video i don't know what else there
is how so how do you feel about
different learning they often do yes
doesn't come uh the research doesn't
come down to favorably on this idea of
learning styles which is uh what you're
talking about
yeah but it's one of those things that
there's something like it that's true
and so uh researchers uh
really don't like it because as stated
it's probably false but
the thing that it's that is sort of true
is that people do have different
abilities
so some people are better with visual
things and some people are better at
like music and some people are better at
sports that's a kind of
you know an obvious truth oh okay um the
thing that is
is questioned or which has not been
supported by research is the idea
that given a piece of information so
given i'm learning geography for
instance that
if i were a musical person that i should
be presenting that as an
like a podcast or if i'm a visual person
it needs to be pictures
i think uh the research basically shows
that you know
in that sense you know there's going to
be some people that are better at
geography and some people that are
better at music
but it's not that you know you teach the
music people in a certain way and they
learn the geography better
that being said though i i i do agree
with that kind of broad scientific
conclusion
but again that's a very
education-centric viewpoint which is
how do you run a class so that you can
benefit the students and i'm always
trying to invert that question of how do
you as a learner get
what you want to get done accomplished
and so i think there's a lot of
opportunity there for flexibility in
trying different types of projects and
styles
that work for you and it may not be for
some deep cognitive reason
that you know oh well i'm an audio
person so i have to listen
but it may just be related to what we
were talking about that like
you know your programming exercises seem
really boring until you're making a
video game or your language learning
activities don't seem interesting to you
until you're watching
you know japanese television or
something so it's not that
i think there's necessarily a specific
learner-centric thing that well
all audio stuff is better or all
kinesthetic stuff is going to be better
for me
but i think finding your own custom way
of approaching the problem that
integrates your goals your motivation
um are you more introverted or
extroverted or you i think those are all
really really valuable but that's much
more from uh
from a learner's perspective i think
than you know how do we teach all
kids given their diversity so you're
basically suggesting that people need a
reason to learn
and once they have a motivation or a
reason to learn it's just
way easier right which is actually kind
of yeah
i would go i would go further i would
say and you know i say this being
someone who's devoted his entire life to
learning about learning and learning is
very important to me but i think that
people don't like learning in a basic
way that
our entire sort of instinct is an
organism is to make
things habitual and familiar and
understood
so learning is a kind of it's like
exercise like our whole
inertia as an organism is to conserve
calories and not do
unnecessary physical expenditure
similarly if there's a way you can do it
which makes it familiar and like you
don't have to
learn some new way of doing it that's
sort of the default and so this is the
sort of upstream that we're doing
whenever we're learning anything new
is that it's always easier to maybe not
do that thing right
and so the problem is that our own
familiarity of our lives of like where
we are
can trap us you know we're in jobs we
don't like we're in relationships we
don't like we don't have any interesting
hobbies we just sit around and play with
our phones all day
and this kind of that's the you know the
sitting on the couch equivalent of
exercise to your mental activity
and it's hard it's hard to learn guitar
it's hard to learn french it's hard to
you know switch to a new career where
you were you were good at your old job
and you're not good at your new job
these are all very difficult problems
and so i think the motivation component
is essential because
you're you're swimming upstream against
this biological impulse to
conserve energy and do things the way
that you always do them
but i think there's power in that if you
you know just the way some people get
really into running or get really into
some kind of physical activity because
it becomes a source of confidence to
them
if you can embark on your own projects
and figure something out it's like oh
well if i could do that what else could
i do what are something else that
i've wanted to do that maybe i put off
just because it seemed too difficult or
frustrating i like that
that works uh okay we've got more
questions
okay okay how do you feel about routines
like morning routines
are you a morning routine person yeah
well i have uh
i have a young child now two years
saying you have a toddler i have a 15
month old so i am
really into routines these days actually
uh having a child
is like the ultimate habit creation
machine because you're now living on
this schedule of okay when does he take
a nap when does he wake up
so i do really think routines are
valuable
i think morning routines are
particularly valuable especially if you
feel like your life has a lot of chaotic
elements in it
because it's usually the what you do
when you wake up until
like the day starts to unravel like you
have some control in that beginning part
whereas near the end of the day when
you're exhausted and you've been dealing
with meetings and emergencies and random
things have been coming up
um it's often a lot harder to assert
that like this is what i want my day to
be about so i really think
morning routines can be helpful and
whenever i've been doing any kind of
intensive project
i very often like get going on it right
first thing in the morning
just because it establishes that so we
were talking about this mit project i
did and it was very intensive because i
was doing the classes at a faster than
normal pace and
in the beginning that would be what i do
i like wake up at seven and you know i'm
still in my pajamas and i just like open
the book and start for like an hour and
then i'd have breakfast
and for me that was just a forcing
function of i'm not going to spend three
hours doing
things that are unrelated and then okay
i'm going to get to the book it's like
no this is what my day is about right
now i'm going to do this
and so there's lots of different morning
routines i don't want to suggest any
particular one is is the right one
a lot of people like exercising in the
morning i'm more of a afternoon exercise
guy but
you have to figure out what works for
you but i think this general idea
of using that consistent part of the day
to say okay this is what my days can be
about the world might
send me off course but at least i'm
going to have started on the path that i
wanted to go on
okay i've had a number of people on the
podcast and
this morning routine thing comes up
frequently and
a lot of people are like you know you
wake up you do like
meditate journal exercise kind of that
row and then i started following
somebody on instagram i think his name's
craig ballantine
and he's like no you you you put the
most important thing in the morning
first that you want to get done because
then you just
do it and so what you're suggesting is
or what at least what you've done
is you put the task that needs what the
most
cognitive ability right in the morning i
mean yeah
i think for me right now for instance as
we were just talking about
uh having children's stuff like i'm not
doing my work first thing in the morning
because first thing in the morning is
you know
take care of my son my wife has to you
know exercise and shower and
then we're making breakfast and this
kind of stuff so it's not the case i'm
like okay you put all that aside i'm
going to be reading a book for an hour
and a half
i've done that in the past i think the
right way of viewing it is not so much
that there's any particular activity
that has to come first but viewing it as
you know it's going to start fraying
your your day is going to go in a lot of
random directions that maybe you're not
going to predict because stuff's going
to come up
and it's going to branch from that
starting point so if your starting point
is
oh yeah i slept in and i shouldn't have
you know i was
checking these emails but i wasn't
supposed to be doing that for an hour
and a half and then
i'm on reddit and then it's really hard
at 10 am to be like oh okay let's get
down to work and let's like reestablish
what we're doing whereas if you are
already on the kind of the right track
so to speak with whatever your goals
were and whatever the track was
um i think that can work so some people
like the
to work immediately other people like
the you know like you said this sort of
kind of you could call them self-care
routines or do meditation and
taking a shower and making your bed so i
don't really think there's a right
answer
but i think the broader idea of um
it's much easier to assert your
independence and control
first thing in the morning than at 4 pm
i think i think that's generally true
okay i might have to switch things
around i've been doing kind of the
self-care route
but i'm trying to get this one project
done and i have it scheduled in at like
11 in the morning and for the hours
preceding 11 in the morning all i'm
doing
is like damn it i'm gonna have to do
that project
like for like hours if i just did it in
the morning first thing then maybe i
wouldn't have to do that
and i mean i think there's nothing wrong
either with taking a more
um radical approach to some of your
goals too i think some people
they view things in a very restrictive
way i was just having a conversation
with a guy
who had done some really incredible
things it was after the book so i didn't
get to include them but
you know really came out of nowhere and
learned all these things and
and he was just mentioning me very
casually well i've been able to do this
because you know i wake up at 4 a.m
every day so like between 4 a.m and like
yeah one of those guys at 9 00 am that's
that's when i get on my stuff time
and i mean it was uh it was it was
really interesting to me because
you know for a lot of people i mean i i
don't want to wake up at 4am either
but the i waking up at 4am would just be
out of the question or even like i'm
going to wake up at 6 and do it for like
an hour
or two before i have breakfast would be
out of the question so
it's not to say that you have to do that
i think it's just that
um you know if there's one message of
the book is that we tend to view
oh there's only one way to do things and
when that way
we can't go there with it i guess it's
just impossible and so
you know i think the approach of well
okay maybe i could do it
an hour or two in the morning if this is
really important to me and a lot of
people i know have
made strides on important projects to
them with that morning time
okay i'm gonna do that i'm gonna switch
things up
um okay do you have techniques to deal
with distraction
yeah i think focus is super important
for learning um
there's the thing that i i hate more
than anything is this idea that we can
multitask and
i'm gonna be listening to music and have
the tv on in the background and i'm also
texting someone while i'm doing some
kind of
math problem and this is not how the
brain works i mean
anything that involves learning is going
to use your full attention because
you're having to create new pathways in
the brain to deal with information
the frontal part of your brain this is
the sort of executive processing center
this is the part that it has to switch
tasks so if you are
looking on your phone it is switching to
okay we got to deal with this
relationship this conversation situation
and then back to the math problem you
have to switch back and forth
and it doesn't do this instantly some
people it does it a bit faster it's one
of the things that happens when you age
is that as you get older it's harder to
shift there's research that shows that
it's much more important when you're
older to to focus on this
but being able to focus is super
important so things that i think are
really important there's a lot of boring
stuff like
just remove all the distractions from
where you're learning or where you're
working on things you know turn off your
phone
don't have the internet all these kind
of things so these are things people
know about
they don't always do but they know about
them the other thing that i think is
important
is that our impulse to distraction is
not
it's not inherent so the what i mean by
that is that
your desire to check your phone is not
just a function of
well i really like my phone it's also
based on well in this kind of situation
in the past i often look at my phone and
looking at the phone is more interesting
than what i'm doing right now
and so this is again related to this
habit idea we were talking about but one
thing you can do to make it easier for
yourself to focus
is just to consistently not have these
kinds of temptations
in certain contexts so that you know
when i'm in this
when i'm in the library for instance i
leave my phone at home right or
or i put my phone in silent at the
bottom of my bag so it's not visible
and if you do that consistently for a
while when you're in the library it
doesn't occur to you to look at your
phone because that's just not something
you do there in that situation
and you can go broader than this you can
think about you know your whole life but
basically
how effortful an activity is is often
based on
how what are the alternatives that
you're considering in that moment
so if it's between doing a math problem
and you know looking on instagram
then instagram's going to win most the
time right so the way that you make it
win
is that you're not really comparing math
problem and instagram because
oh yeah i wasn't thinking about that
because i i checked my instagram
in a different place in a different
location i don't do it right here when
i'm trying to learn or i'm trying to
study
and so i think this kind of context
control where you
basically train yourself as a new habit
to not have these kinds of distractions
in certain environments
can make it so that yeah i just i put in
an hour or two on this project and it
was
not that bad because there wasn't really
anything else that i was going to get
distracted by
in that time and do you think there are
ways to train yourself
into new habits kind of sneakily so it's
not so painful at the beginning
like you said if you if you you know put
your phone on airplane mode put it at
the bottom of your bag you're just
more and more less likely to grab it
because it's not dinging like are there
sneaky ways to do this so that
like i said is not painful yeah i mean i
think
i don't think there's a way that you can
completely remove the effort but i think
what people are talking about when they
say that
is that this is too hard for me right
now so what you're suggesting is too
hard for me
right now so whenever that's the case
i'm always trying to look at
how can you reframe the situation so
your goal is something
something approachable right that gets
you in the right direction so we were
talking about that with the case of
going to the gym that
if going there and doing this two hour
you know
high intensity workout just you know oh
i don't want to do that i'm too tired
today
then just going to the gym can you know
help start
solve that problem and so for me i think
that you know a lot of people get
benefit from doing things like
pomodoros and these kind of techniques
where you okay i'm going to set a timer
for 20 minutes and
just study for 20 minutes and i think
where those kinds of devices can be
helpful
is that they allow you to break down
that problem of if
contemplating studying for three hours
just fills you with dread and you can't
get yourself to do it and you certainly
can't get yourself to do it if you don't
have your phone next to you because oh
my god that would be too awful
then okay let's put the phone away for
like 20 minutes
and and build up to it so that's one way
of doing it
the other way of doing it is to reframe
what you're trying to actually do
so a good friend of mine cal newport has
a book digital minimalism and he
suggests doing this digital declutter
which is basically 30 days where you
kind of get rid of
your digital devices i've had somebody
i've had somebody mention
cal newport's digital minimalism to me
for probably a year and a half and i
just keep being like
yeah i get i get it i'm not reading that
yet
wow and now it comes up again anyway
so but the basic idea is that um
because we've have this context
situation where
for most of us our phone is with us all
the time
um you know our social media everything
is just a click away
so the basic default we're dealing with
is that our context is that those are
always alternatives so it's always
possible to check your phone it's always
possible
so if you're thinking of something hard
you have to do you're always kind of
climbing this sort of
hill so to speak because right next to
you is this really easy activity
there's this hard activity over here and
you have to climb up it and so the idea
is that if you could
move that a bit further away it would be
an easier gradient and so one of the
things
he suggests is doing this um this kind
of cutting it out for a month so you can
kind of reestablish
a new baseline of what you're what
you're trying to do
and you might not want to go to that
extent but i think there can be some
benefit as well of just
getting rid of some of the distractions
without having a lot of goals
for um you know like the gym idea like
you don't have to be doing
something heroically in terms of
studying way more than you normally do
or
working out way more than you normally
do or doing anything more than you
normally do
but just having some of those
distractions in certain contexts okay
i'm not having it for the next month
and then that allows this sort of okay
it's actually easier to focus
so you're not putting the emphasis on
the work you're putting the emphasis on
not having the other things that would
distract you from the work
interesting okay that's probably
something i have to look into
unfortunately
okay so this kind of builds from what we
were just talking about but if
people aren't accomplishing their goals
or if they have a goal and they're not
accomplishing it
do you have suggestions for how to make
that goal more accomplishable
well i think whenever you're not
accomplishing one of the goals you have
you have to look at
what are the possible reasons uh you're
not accomplishing the goal so a very
simple one
is are you putting in the work i mean
that's a that's a pretty obvious one but
if you have certain fitness goals but
you're not going to the gym or you have
a goal to learn a language but you're
never actually practicing it or you're
never actually using it
um and so i i always start with like are
you doing the work would be the starting
point
but sometimes you're doing the work or
you're doing what you think is the work
and you're not making the progress you
want and so in this case this is a
different kind of problem and i think
this
frequently comes up with learning
situations and so
you know i spend a lot of time in the
book talking about how there's always
this
troubleshooting operation i'm like i'm
doing this but i'm not getting it
or i'm studying for this exam but my
score is not improving on the practice
test or
i'm trying to learn a language but it's
you know still really hard i can't do it
and so in these cases i think it's often
useful to experiment to try different
things out and notice what the results
are
and one thing that i find that makes
this powerful too is that if you can
shift out of the shift out of the object
level discussion so the
object level situation is i'm studying
and there is a kind of layer above that
is sort of
looking at your studying and like well
what kind of studying should i do
and i think that that can be beneficial
because when you're in the studying
mindset and you're it's not working
there's frustration
and there is often feelings of
inadequacy or failure
but if you shift out of that and you're
looking at what kind of studying should
do
that kind of takes all those
difficulties and makes them a sort of
its own puzzle that you are trying to
solve and so i think that can be
beneficial if you're looking at it so
often when i would be working on
projects i would do this where like
maybe after the end of each day if it
was a full-time project or the
after the end of each week if it was
something i was doing part-time i would
do this kind of stepping back
and reassessing what i'm doing so it'd
be like okay well you know
i i'm not understanding these concepts
so i need to do more work on that or
you know this thing wasn't working out
very well my pronunciation here isn't
very good
or you know this technique that i was
using i'm kind of hitting a dead end
with that like i can't go any further
with that maybe i need to find a new
method
and i know that's a little abstract but
i think where that helps is that if you
are
you know spending a lot of time trying
to learn something trying to do
something and you're hitting a wall
constantly it's good to step back and
sort of see that situation for what it
is so if you're trying to start a
business and it's been like another
month without sales
it's useful to not just be in the thick
of things doing stuff but to step back
and be like okay well how am i spending
my time every day
these activities seem to be working
these don't seem to be working i maybe
need to do more of this this seems to be
a weakness
and learning to kind of detach yourself
from the situation
to to view it that way can often be very
helpful because once you find a new
strategy you often have renewed
confidence in what you're doing and if
you just get stuck doing the same thing
over and over again
i mean that is why a lot of people give
up they tried something they did it for
a while didn't work
and then they gave up and so the more
you can alternate between doing the work
and
shifting out and being like hmm what
kind of work should i be doing
i think that that often helps you get
out of those ruts
okay and then that makes sense one other
question
how how do people know when the goals
they have are too big
well i think that so this is a good
question because i think there's nothing
wrong with having big goals but i think
the problem is that big goals on their
own don't really do anything
they don't inspire any action today so
if your goal is like well one day i'm
going to be a billionaire
well what does that tell you to do right
now nothing right like
there's nothing there's no like
plausible sequence you can work out in
your head where
me doing x right now is going to make me
a billionaire you know 30 years from now
and so you know it might might restrict
some of your
like smaller goals but i always feel
like what the process is of setting
is to use that to define the scope for
something smaller so you set a goal that
i'm going to
you know do this in a year and then what
does that mean you're going to do this
month
and then from that month what are you
going to do this week what are you going
to do
today what are you going to do right now
and so that is the
process so it's not really about goals
being too big or too small
it's just about recognizing that action
is always in the moment like what you're
doing is always
right now and so if there's no
connection between what you're doing
right now and the goal then the goal
might as well not exist it's just a
fantasy and so i think that's a real
skill
of taking some big project like you know
with my project when i was doing the mit
project was like i have to learn all
these 33 classes okay
33 classes in a year i need to do about
one every week and a half okay
i've got this class i'm going to do
right now i can do that in about
10 days okay what do i have to do today
i have to make sure i get through these
lectures where
these problems says do this okay i'm
going to watch these lectures today i'm
going to watch this lecture right now
and that sort of zooming in on okay
right now i have to finish this and i
have to do this right now
is is super important and that's
particularly for complicated goals but
even for goals like where you're doing
the same thing repeatedly like
you know you're just you're building a
business and you're you know doing the
same activity to to get clients or
you're
um you know losing weight and you're
exercising every day i think it's very
important to have this okay yeah i want
to be running an iron man but at the
same time
i got to lace up my shoes right now and
get jogging
break it down into something smaller and
achievable each day
something like that yeah and i think the
more
the more your goals tell you what to do
right now i think the more
effective they'll be ah so turn a goal
into an action
got it okay scott young thank you very
much for coming on
uh i have linked your book ultralearning
below
if anyone would like to check it out i
would recommend it it was good i read it
um if people can find you online where
do they go
yeah so you can go to my website they
want to find you online yeah
i should say if you're if you're not
sick of me already you can go to
www.scottheyoung.com
and uh also you can check out the book
um
as you mentioned and my handle is
usually scott h young so
instagram wherever you want to follow me
if you want to get some updates
okay thank you very much thank you
thanks for having me
you